como esta nada aunque esta no ha sido la
más afectada Así que es una donde hay
varias varios edificios de ruidos esta
mañana hemos estado en otras ciudades
con muchísimos más edificios hablamos
por ejemplo la ciudad de Antioquia cuya
gran mayoría de los edificios ha sido
derrumbado por este seísmo de 7,8 en la
escala de uno de los más grandes en la
historia de la corta República de
Turquía que este año ha cumplido los 100
años el último gran terremoto que se
recuerda en este país fue en 1999 cuando
cerca de Estambul murieron 17.000
personas muchas más que es en un
terremoto mucho más endeble que ese que
sin embargo se ha cobrado la vida y se
podrá cobrar la vida de muchos miles más
porque según explican las autoridades
hay aún muchas personas atrapadas bajo
las runas de muchos edificios y con unas
temperaturas que en la noche bajan
varios grados bajo cero sobre todo en
las regiones más norteñas y más lejanas
al mar estas personas según explican
muchos de los vecinos que esperan que
estas personas sean rescatado estén
probablemente ya fallecidas esperando
sus cuerpos a que sean rescatado debajo
de las runas